we begin the day with the seeds of
russia's war in ukraine and what the
world may be forced to reap
today the u.n secretary general said
that the war now threatens all of
humanity he said vladimir putin's
decision to put his country's nuclear
arsenal on high alert has once again
made the threat of a nuclear conflict
clear and present and he warned that the
fighting has placed the safety of
ukraine's nuclear power plants in
question and there is also the worry
that now has a place at our kitchen
tables russia and ukraine are among the
world's largest grain exporters this
spring if farmers are fighting instead
of planting global food prices will
skyrocket and later this year in poorer
countries many could be faced with food
shortages i want you to take a listen to
what the u.n secretary general antonio
gutierrez said earlier today
this war goes far beyond ukraine
it is also an assault on the world's
most vulnerable people and countries
food
fuel and 30 large fertilizer prices are
skyrocketing
supply chains are being disrupted
and the costs and delays of
transportation of imported goods when
available
are at record levels
and all of this is eating the poorest
the hardest
and planting the seeds for political
instability and unrest around the globe
further escalation of the war whether by
accident or design
threatens all of humanity
raising the alert of russian nuclear
forces is a bone chilling development
the prospect of nuclear conflict once
unthinkable
is now back within the realm of
possibility
almost three million people have fled
ukraine since fighting began there
almost three weeks ago once thriving
cities are now in ruins trapped
civilians are running out of food and
water faced with the impossible choice
of risking their lives if they stay
or also risking coming under russian
fire if they attempt to flee
this bus was struck by parts of a
russian missile in a northern district
of kiev
the explosion damaged electric cables
and nearby buildings
earlier firefighters rescued people from
the smoldering ruins of a nine-story
apartment building
hit during an early morning attack
part of renewed fighting on the
outskirts of the capital
the city has so far resisted russia's
advance
a rocket hit the building
at first i saw the blast and then five
or six seconds later there was an
explosion
the entrance door was simply blown out
we really weren't expecting this we
thought nothing bad could happen to a
small building on the outskirts of kiev
we went to sleep as usual at around five
o'clock bam
i couldn't understand where i was
we were in our pajamas
russia denies targeting civilians and is
holding faster its description of its
war as a special military operation
the defense ministry in moscow says its
forces have destroyed nearly 4 000
objects of ukraine's military
infrastructure
among its targets a military training
ground near the polish border in western
ukraine hit on sunday
it was moscow's closest strike so far to
nato territory
still president vladimir zelinsky
indicated peace talks could be making
progress
representatives of our countries are
holding daily talks via video conference
our delegation has a clear task to do
everything to arrange the meeting of the
presidents
but we need this path
a path desperately needed in eastern
regions under sustained russian assault
this is the city of kramatorsk
eyewitness video from a resident there
showed destruction to our apartment in a
five-story building in the aftermath of
an air raid
well it is clear that the russian
invasion of ukraine has created a
humanitarian crisis that now stretches
across europe and as russian forces
intensify their attacks the threat of
fighting spilling over into nato
territory is also growing my first guest
tonight was director of policy planning
at nato when russia annexed crimea he
says nato has a moral and a strategic
responsibility to push back against
russian aggression in ukraine i'm happy
to welcome to the program tonight
fabrice poltier mr protean it's good to
have you with us
the war in ukraine is getting closer and
closer it seems to nato territory with
the weekend's attack for example on that
military base now you've said that
demands a clear message from
nato what should that message be
well first the message should be that we
are not going to let ourselves
intimidated
by vladimir putin's war of aggression
and that nato and nato countries will
continue to support in every meaningful
way
president zelensky and the ukrainian
forces in defending the territory so
that means the arms shipment that have
been going on over the past few weeks
should continue and i would argue should
be amplified
in number but also in quality and
including air defense systems that will
allow the ukrainians to basically
protect the territory at least the
western part of ukraine and to avoid
this kind of attacks we have seen
yesterday
so you agree that a no-fly zone
over
ukraine
by nato
that's a no-go
i i i think that it's important to
listen to what the ukrainian leadership
and what the ukrainian forces need
and and i think it's important to give
them what they need to prosecute that
war and push back on vladimir putin so
if they ask for fighter jets i think we
should do everything possible to provide
them with what they need
and i also know from very good sources
that they are asking for air defense
systems medium range air defense systems
to be able to shoot down russian fighter
jets and shoot down russian missiles and
i think we can provide that we have that
in our in our in our stock in nato and
it's a question of political decision
here mr project do you think that we
have an accurate picture of the
strength and stability of the russian
military
i think it's a mixed picture
clearly
we we've seen a russian military
struggling with basic planning
communications
so i think it's a different story from
what we have seen since after the 2008
georgian war where the russian military
allegedly went through a pretty
significant reform and injection of
resources however uh you know whilst in
the past we may have overestimated the
russian military it's also important not
to underestimate the russian military
because they're still capable of
conducting a pretty you know large
operations but more importantly they're
capable of destroying and killing many
people and this is what we're seeing in
ukraine right now
what do you make of these u.s reports
that russia has asked china for military
and economic aid in its war on ukraine
i think this is probably one of the most
critical points of that war so far
and should china uh come to the aid
including from a military point of view
uh or to uh russia
i think that war which we can argue is a
regional war a
european war could well quickly turn
into a global war and this is why i
think there was a very stern warning
from president biden's national security
adviser jack sullivan to the chinese
about the economic consequences of
aiding the russians so we are at a very
critical point as to whether that war
can be contained regionally or whether
it might actually
spill over globally
well how does nato how can it plan in
this environment
we've had the director of the cia say
that vladimir putin
is living in a propaganda bubble and the
mindset that the west cannot reliably
read i mean when we push vladimir putin
how do we know
when we've pushed him too far or when
we've pushed him into a corner
well it's not because he's living under
you know some kind of wicked ideology
that is an that is not a rational actor
and everything in the past shows that he
is responding to strengths with much
more prudence and caution than we might
think so i think it's time for nato to
take its courage in two hands and be
willing to control escalation vis-a-vis
vladimir putin rather than what we have
now where putin is escalating at will
and defining the terms
of that a confrontation
you know i asked you earlier this
evening i'll ask you again you know many
assume that vladimir putin is a rational
actor
but how can we be sure
that he is making decisions based on
what
the rest of the world would consider to
be
reasoned
logic
yeah a rational actor how do we know
that that's what he is
you can never be 100 sure
but i think what you can also be sure is
that doing nothing
is actually having a huge humanitarian
economic and actually security costs not
just for ukraine but for for the whole
of europe so we are not in a scenario
where on one hand we do nothing and the
risk is zero and on the other hand we do
everything and the risk is enormous i
think it's about how we grey how we can
gradually push back on vladimir putin
and make him fail
and again everything shows that yes the
uh putin and the russian forces are
aggressive and are disruptive but
whenever there has been a pushback in
the past either in syria or elsewhere
they're actually backtrack so i think we
have to assume that indeed they are
still rational enough to know the cost
and especially the devastating cost of
of certain actions and to backtrack
well i think many people in the world
hope that you are exactly
correct with that assessment fabrice
potato former director of policy
planning with nato mr poltier we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
pleasure
[Music]
what happened to you uh we were we
crossed one the first bridge in european
we're going to
film other refugees leaving
and we got into a car somebody offered
to take us to the other bridge
and we crossed a checkpoint and they
start shooting at us
so the driver turned around and they
kept shooting it's two of us my friend's
friend renault
and he's been shot and left behind
and how is he i don't know
that was the u.s journalist juan
arredondo being interviewed from inside
a hospital he was injured in a suburb of
kiev that has been under heavy
bombardment by russian forces for days
arlendonda did not know at the time but
his colleague brent reneau
died at the scene reno is the first
foreign journalist killed in ukraine
since russia's invasion began several
media crews have been attacked while
reporting on the war ukrainian president
zielinski says that russia is
deliberately attacking journalists
an american journalist brent renaud was
killed today in the kiev region
his colleague was wounded
it was a deliberate attack by russian
troops they knew what they were doing
but it seems like not everyone in the
west knows what the russians are doing
my next guest is the deputy director of
the international press institute that's
a global network that aims to protect
press freedom scott griffin it's good to
have you with us tonight
let me ask you do we have any evidence
that
russian forces are targeting journalists
in ukraine
well we don't have independent
confirmation of that we have obviously
the statements by the ukrainian
authorities uh and certainly that is a
plausible explanation of what happened
uh given
we know that russia is targeting
civilians in ukraine so that is
obviously possible
but we don't have certainty about what
happened in that incident
what we do know for sure is that under
international humanitarian law
journalists are civilians and civilians
are never acceptable targets in a
conflict
and so this would be a war crime uh and
our position obviously is ipi is that
this needs to be investigated
and those responsible whether that
ultimately is russian forces
or somebody else needs to be held
responsible um so it's also worth
mentioning this is the first death of a
foreign journalist in ukraine but not
the first death of a media worker
actually during the russian shelling of
the television tower in kiev a camera
operator was killed in that attack as
well so we see that the situation is
becoming more dangerous for the press
day after day are you concerned that
ukraine may soon become
simply too dangerous for foreign
journalists to be
something similar to what we saw happen
in syria
absolutely i mean the situation is very
fluid and there's no question that it's
becoming more dangerous every day
the attacks on the russian attacks are
becoming more intense more cities are
coming under shelling also larger
portions of ukrainian territory are
coming under attack so these are going
to be very difficult decisions for media
organizations to be making in the next
few days not to mention the next few
weeks about how to approach the
situation when to possibly pull their
journalists
out
and what's really important here is that
journalists who are still there
we need to make sure they have the
proper equipment their organizations
need to ensure that they are properly
prepared and trained to go in these
situations which are very dangerous uh
people need journalists need to be
prepared for that scott do you think
they are
do you think journalists are prepared i
mean because we were talking in the
newsroom today you know we could get in
the car and drive it would be a long
drive but we could drive to ukraine and
be in the middle of a war zone i mean
you've got that country being flooded
with foreign journalists
do you think that they've moved in too
hastily are they prepared
for what the russian forces could
present them
look some are and some aren't there are
journalists who have experience
reporting from war zones and their media
organizations have the means
to provide them with the necessary
safety equipment although no one has
perfect safety in these types of
situations but we also know there are
media organizations including you know
in countries neighboring ukraine that
have never experienced a war zone
and they don't have the means to buy
armored vests or other types of
equipment so this is a big concern i
think a lot of media organizations and
journalists were caught off guard in the
early days of the conflict i do think
that is hopefully changing people are
realizing what needs to happen before
going into these situations but again
there is i think a wide range in terms
of preparedness and we hope that media
organizations who are sending their
people in
and also the freelancers who they are
working with
are prepared
do you worry that this war could be a
defining
event for an entire generation of
journalists to be the last
major war
the war in iraq had embedded journalists
but this is you know the first war
really
sids
maybe vietnam for americans where you've
seen
a lot of us journalists
rush to a war zone and that's the case
also here in germany is for other
countries is this going to be a defining
event
well it's obviously possible we're still
in the early days of this conflict we
don't know we hope the violence also
doesn't escalate um i do want to say a
few words also about the situation of
ukrainian journalists obviously the
situation is
complex and difficult for foreign
journalists and you may well be right
this becomes a defining moment we are
also focused very much on what is
happening to
local journalists in ukraine for them
the situation is also extremely
difficult because it's more difficult
for them to leave the country and
they're also more intent on staying to
cover this conflict for their local
communities but obviously also for the
wider world and as i said most of them
actually are staying in the country at
the moment
that may change of course depending on
the course that this conflict uh takes
but they are also uh you know on the
ground the first ones they're reporting
together with foreign journalists coming
in so we're also very much focused right
now on their safety scott before we let
you go i just want to get your reaction
to what has gone viral on social media
this evening and that's the video of a
woman going inside a russian news studio
during a live news broadcast going
behind the anchor with a poster
protesting the war saying no war i mean
the fact that she was able to do that is
amazing in russia
what's your reaction
well it's astonishing that she was able
to to do that but i think uh what i was
just reading also that the newspaper
novaya gazietta which is one of the very
very last independent media working in
russia reported on this incident but had
to black out
what the protester was saying because
they're not able to use the necessary
words to actually cover this incident
they're not able to say war or invasion
and i don't know if people understand
the level of censorship that is
happening in russia at the moment not
only obviously our protests being
violently suppressed but nearly all
independent media have been forced out
of the country
closed hundreds of journalists have left
the country over the past
few weeks and again authorities are
using sort of orwellian language to
describe this operation
and bring the hammer down on any
journalists or media who dared to report
what is actually happening in ukraine as
a war or an invasion and we fear that
this censorship which is unprecedented
in russia since the fall of the soviet
union
is only going to increase things look
very serious and very negative in russia
at the moment and we can assume with a
high degree of certainty that the woman
the protester who held up that
sign in the
russian news broadcast she's going to
prison isn't she
obviously very likely very possible um
we've seen
as i'm sure you have as well shocking
videos of people on the street even one
i've seen you know holding a sign that
said nothing a blank sign
and you know immediately being taken
away by security forces you know we
understand that these protesters face a
sort of different fate some are
released immediately with warnings
others may be held for longer periods of
time but the strategy of the authorities
is fairly clear here it's a shutdown
immediately
any type of
any type of critical gestures in public
with violent force to prevent this from
turning into a wider movement which is
also the explanation for this violent
crackdown so that people inside russia
don't see the images of what is actually
happening in ukraine the kremlin
obviously fears
the public reaction from this
scott griffin deputy director of the
international press institute scott we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
thank you